the highly anticipated February Nintendo
Direct has come and gone and with it we
got a brand new and probably final
trailer for tears of the Kingdom there
were tons of new things shown from new
monsters to new Chic attack and even the
reveal of what I assumed to be
ganondorf's voice so allow me to piece
by piece break down and analyze this
trailer for all that juicy reveals it
contains the trailer opens with a shot
of rainy Hyrule with three lightning
strikes appearing at once which already
seems to symbolize the Triune nature of
the Triforce we can see what's mostly a
familiar landscape with a few
differences such as the green magic
Spirals and Malice spewing Death
Mountain which were both seen in a
previous trailer as the lighting darkens
we can see a pool of malice beside the
green spiral structure the next shot is
of an enemy camp which does look
reminiscent of bakoblin camps in the
first game but this time the bat-like
keys monsters seem to have mutated into
a different species entirely with
frog-like heads and legs the next shot
is very interesting because in the
original trailers we couldn't see any
sheikah Towers in the distance however
in this trailer we can see what appears
to be shika Towers but upon closer
inspection might be something different
because it has a slightly different
shape my guess is that fitting with the
theme of the monsters becoming smarter
in tears of the Kingdom perhaps they've
found some way to deactivate or alter
the towers and are now setting up camps
at their bases building some sort of
structures alongside them and using
spotlights to light up their work though
what their plan is is currently unknown
there's also another of the neon green
land markings in this shot but it
appears different from the ones in the
previous trailer in this next shot we
can see another one of the sky islands
of Sky rule as I like to call it above
Hyrule far below there is also another
floating island that appears to have
been created by the same ancient people
group responsible for creating the
ancient material showcased in all the
tiers of the Kingdom trailers we can
also see another different landmarking
here as the cloud moves away the next
shot is incredibly interesting we can
see the goblins and Liz alfos spewing
the dark red malice from the trailers
implying that ganon's magic has not only
returned but is now well supercharged
perhaps this has even enhanced their
intelligence because we can also see a
bakoblin mind meaning for materials as
we back up and inspect more of the area
from the strange trees to the swirling
mushroom-like yellow structure to the
grass that doesn't really look like
grass it's clear to me that this is not
Hyrule meaning this must be somewhere up
in skyrule which would explain all of
the different mushroom-like structures
and the strange ruins positioned further
behind it also proves that we will be
facing familiar enemies up in the sky
next up we have a shot of lake hylia and
are allowed to hear what I assume is
none other than ganondorf's voice but
more on that in a second visually we are
shown a giant flaming three-headed
dragon guarding the bridge as well as
the floating Hyrule castle and Death
Mountain both of which are spewing
malice the next shot is of the familiar
hateno Village from the Viewpoint of the
lab it looks no different other than the
fact that one of these new spiral
structures is shown here on this cliff
and as you can see from in-game in
breath of the wild the spiral is
completely new where previously there
was a giant tree I'm not sure if this
means some trees can turn into these
spirals but it seems to have completely
replaced it either way in the background
we can see a giant blue pillar like
structure that I can only assume is new
since there was nothing like that before
in breath of the wild and it may be one
of the new blue structures that resemble
shika Towers the next shot is of Link
standing within a Hylian structure
looking out towards a Blood Moon this
seems to imply that the blood moon is
going to be the Catalyst for ganondorf's
return but more on that in an upcoming
theory that I'm already thinking up as
we are given a close-up shot of the
terrifyingly red blood moon ganondorf's
words end which from start to finish are
rise rise my servants sweep over Hyrule
eliminate this Kingdom and her allies
leave no survivors this seems like a
pretty cut and dry message from
Ganondorf to his risen by the malice of
the blood moon monsters to you know
eliminate everyone in Hyrule and her
allies which either means the gorons and
Zora and Gerudo or the other kingdoms
outside Hyrule but in my opinion it's
most likely a reference to the other
races of hyruleans within Hyrule we are
then shown the floating Hyrule Castle as
literal flying shards of malice spew out
of something my guess is being possibly
Death Mountain since that would fit with
the eruptions that death is known for
although when the camera pans towards
the ground the structures we are shown
are definitely new and More in line with
the sky rule structures than those on
Hyrule so this might be a completely new
flying Island next we are shown an
explosion of malice out of a strange
shape that I can only assume is the
ganitor of corpse but it's very hard to
make out for sure then we are shown a
shot of crumbling volcanic rock perhaps
if this happens right after the
explosion that we just saw and if that
explosion does come from ganondorf's
Corpse whatever's crumbling here might
have been the area that he was encased
within after this we are shown the
familiar side of Hyrule Castle breaking
apart as it's lifted off the ground then
we're given a fast sweeping view of the
great plateau and the Temple of Time
complete with a new landmarking located
nearby as the sky redens from the malice
of the blood moon we are then shown by
coblins with even newer pointed horns
being hit by these shards of malice and
presumably becoming powered up and more
intelligent leading to the mining
operations we saw earlier it appears all
monsters are being powered up in the
next shot from hynix's to stall enemies
to Liz all foes and moblins our next
shot is of link racing upon a horse that
greatly resembles Epona and in the
background we can see a large blocky
structure the next quick shot is of what
I assume to be a valley perhaps in the
Garuda region with a dark substance
spewing from underneath the Earth
probably malice next we see another
chica trap or trial as they are fond of
calling their traps which entails six
guardian-like appendages that surround
link who look surprised by this and is
standing inside a cube-like sheikaru the
arm in front of Link has a different
attachment perhaps this means it's the
head or main arm of the contraption next
we're shown more shots of the newly
empowered monsters alongside blocky
creatures presumably fallen from the sky
above link runs away from one of the new
hinexes and Glides above the Thunder
Plateau then we're shown a close-up of
Link riding his horse across one of
these giant land markings which must be
the locations of new important events we
are then shown the new keys like
Monsters carrying the Goblins giving us
a new understanding of just how big
these new mutated monsters are link is
shown fighting new moblins and then a
giant mechanized monster created out of
cubes and located it somewhere in Sky
rule clearly this is a construct of the
ancient technology where then shown
another angle of ganondorf's corpse as
malice now very clearly pulls on his
chest which seems to lead into what
happens at the end of the trailer then
we're shown a shot of Hyrule castle and
Ganondorf conducting his dark ritual
atop the platform where Link and Zelda
discovered him his eyes flash with
malice once again then the trailer
shifts abruptly to link standing in
skyrilla as Zelda's voice is heard she
tells link she's not sure he'll be able
to stop him him being Ganondorf which
could be hinting at another character
helping link out in the game were shown
a beautiful shot of many new islands in
Sky rule some of which Ascend even
higher than what was previously shown
and all of which come in many different
shapes and sizes link once again
descends toward Hyrule below and we can
see some of these floating islands
behind him but there's no way to tell
what they are at this point or what's on
top of them link runs alongside one of
the land markings down on Hyrule and we
can see a few of the new tower
structures in the background which do
look less like shika Towers now that
they're in the daylight link showcases a
new Arrow type that he can fire which
has the ability to home in on enemies
presumably this new weapon is the result
of Link's adventures in Sky rule link is
then shown Shield surfing down railing
that I assume was created by either the
gorons or ganondorf's new monsters since
they're clearly performing some sort of
mining operations in the game in the
background we can see Sky rule I'm not
sure if what Link's currently on is in
skyrule or not since the ground he's
beside is so close to the camera as link
nears the roadblock we can see new
mining carts and boxes that were not
previously seen in breath of the wild
the bakoblins are wielding Rusty
Claymores which implies that at least
some of the weapons are returning link
then rotates a mechanism that rotates a
much larger structure very similar to
the sheikah puzzles that do the same
thing in the sheikah shrines below
although interestingly enough it looks
like this structure is improved upon
because it allows link to rotate it
based off of one set axis at a time as
opposed to the sometimes frustrating
free motion of the shika puzzles next we
are shown link wield a giant two-handed
ancient technology weapon that fires an
explosive blast at a stone talus in the
background we can see lots of luminous
stones and the stone Tellus itself also
appears to be created out of luminous
Stones as well this makes me think that
the shot was taken somewhere in Hyrule
perhaps down in the cave structures that
they're exploring in the other trailers
the next shot is another extremely
interesting one because I believe this
individual shown here is the same
individual shown on the walls in the
previous trailer and for many many
reasons I believe it is hylia herself
but you'll have to check out my previous
theories for that the figure appears to
be female and has the symbology of six
and twin Teardrops on its Tavern and it
reaches down and grabs someone's hand
presumably links but it's quite hard to
tell for sure as it doesn't show as any
more than the hand it does appear to be
the exact same hand though and almost as
if to either prove it is Link's hand or
to purposefully misguide us we are then
shown link standing in Skyrim looking at
his altered hand down on Hyrule in an
area that looks similar to The Great
Plateau link lifts a non-magnetic object
out of the mud with the power of his new
hand on a pillar in the mud we can see a
new ancient kind of chest that again
appears to be linked to all the ancient
green structures that have fallen down
to high rule the object link lifts out
of the mud is shown next on a giant car
that link is driving apparently you'll
be able to farm these ancient materials
and pieces in the game to create these
complex structures such as a car the
power source for this vehicle is shown
behind link and looks like some sort of
container of this pure blue green
ancient energy also the car has
headlights which is pretty cool another
of these craftable vehicles looks to be
a hot air balloon which is held together
by the green substance and yet another
vehicle appears to be a fan propelled
platform which link can also drive
around presumably from Hyrule up to Sky
rule the next shot shows link
approaching the giant slanted Cube
structure which may be the same one that
was shown earlier as the camera zooms
forward we can see skyrill above the new
towers in the distance a pool of malice
to our left as well as a camp that is
possibly a person standing in it and a
glowing Cube falling from the sky and a
bit more of that Cube structure that
appears to have the blue green energy at
its base as the logo fades in next we
are shown ganondorf's corpse apparently
at the scene showcased in the very first
trailer with a tendril of living malice
shooting outward as link faces him with
the master sword which now has malice
all over it Link's hand does as well the
tendril shoots quickly towards link and
then we're shown a close-up of Link who
we can already see the effects of the
malice on as it spreads up his shoulder
he appears to do something then it cuts
to the tendril again then it cuts back
to link who is now without the master
sword and with a much worse looking arm
turning and leaping towards Zelda who's
falling down as shown in three trailers
now seemingly having left the master
sword behind as Zelda's voice can be
heard again saying please lend him your
power it's unclear if link is able to
save Zelda at this point but the most
interesting takeaway is the question of
who Zelda is speaking to presumably the
hymn that Zelda is referring to is link
and the person sees speaking to is
presumably The Entity that changes
Link's arm and grants him new powers
presumably this entity which is
presumably hylia that does end the
trailer and yeah there's a lot that
happened here I'll most likely be making
a ton of theories in the days and weeks
to come so be sure to subscribe if you
haven't already to stay stick around for
all of them and hit that like button if
you're excited for the game and we'll be
picking it up later this year let me
know if there's anything I missed that
you notice in this trailer and that's
all I've got for this one but I'll see
you real soon this is Bandit signing out
peace